wenig rückhalt für den cdu chefin
lasches vorschlag eines sogenannten
rücken lockt downs findet mehr kritik
als zustimmung umstrittene annäherung in
ankara
die eu-spitze wirbt für bessere
beziehungen zur türkei
trotz der schwierigen menschenrechtslage
antreten für den heimatschutz
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer startet einen neuen
freiwilligendienst in der bundeswehr
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster bitten abend willkommen
bei den nachrichten an diesem dienstag
den sport hat heute wieder norbert
lehmann dabei einen schönen grund haben
doch von mir für seinen überraschenden
vorschlag jetzt alles noch mal kurz und
hart herunterzufahren ernte cdu-chef
lasche die jede menge widerspruch
besonders bei spd geführten ländern aber
auch in fdp und csu
welchen sinn überhaupt ein so genannter
brücken lockdown hätte und wie er genau
aussehen sollte das fragen sich dabei
viele klaus brodbeck der versuch wieder
nach vorne zu kommen gestern ein besuch
in einem impfzentrum heute morgen dann
erneuert armin laschet seinen vorschlag
so lange dicht zu machen
bis genügend menschen geimpft sind jetzt
sagen uns die wissenschaftler für diese
brücke bis zu diesem zeitpunkt und da
geht es um zwei drei wochen sollten wir
noch einmal eine anstrengung unternehmen
noch einmal das öffentliche leben
reduzieren die kritik weisend selbst von
der fdp mit der zusammen laschet in nrw
regiert die diskussion über die
kanzlerkandidatur von cdu und csu darf
das pandemie geschehen nicht
beeinträchtigen
einen brücken lockdown der alles
pauschal dicht macht den brauchen wir
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht er wäre
unverhältnismässig harsches vorschlag
noch in dieser woche ein präsenz treffen
mit ministerpräsident innen und
kanzlerin abzuhalten lehnt die spd
weiter ab was wir jetzt brauchen sind
durchdachte und gut vorbereitete
schritte es macht nichts in sich
zusammen zu setzen ohne dass man
sorgfältig das was man dort beschließt
auch vorbereitet hat aus der eigenen cdu
springt heute niemand laschet bei und
konkurrenz söder wird heute abend bei
markus lanz den druck weiter erhöhen
nicht ohne verweis auf die korona
politik das feld in dem laschet gerade
strauchelt da geht es um leben und tod
hier geht es um fragen von kandidaturen
einzelne ambitionen möglicherweise
sicher verantwortung für eine große
aufgabe aber koma ist das was mir immer
nach wie vor sagen macht das ist die
hauptsache
ansonsten ist angst
an der stelle keine kategorie aber an
einigen stellen schade demut nichts 22
uhr 45 heute abend laschet weiß es auch
schlechte tage können lang werden fragen
wie usher konto energy in berlin hat
laschet mit seinem vorschlag nun
gepunktet oder eher ein eigentor
geschossen schack unterlag das ist
deutschland einiges darauf hin dass er
sich keinen gefallen getan hat mit
seinem vorschlag und das in doppelter
hinsicht zum einen wirkt er jetzt in der
runde der mitglieder der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz wie
derjenige der die eigenen guten vorsätze
vergessen hat nämlich vor allem den
vorsatz nur noch gut vorbereitet in die
sitzungen reinzugehen
dafür wäre die zeit jetzt reichlich
knapp wenn man seinen brücken lockdown
vorschlag noch ausarbeiten wollte und
noch viel schlimmer sieht es aus wenn es
um seinen führungsanspruch in der union
geht denn armin laschet ist eben nicht
ein ministerpräsident unter vielen er
ist ein anwärter auf die
kanzlerkandidatur von cdu und csu und
als solcher hätte er für seinen
vorschlag aus den eigenen reihen
deutlich mehr zuspruch bekommen müssen
den hat er heute nicht bekommen
es gibt viele die nichts gesagt haben
oder den vorschlag abgelehnt haben und
es gibt nur sehr wenige nämlich volker
bouffier und herr kretschmar aus sachsen
die sich an seine seite gestellt haben
und gesagt haben darüber kann man ja
zumindest mal reden es ist ein guter
vorschlag das ist erschreckend wenig für
jemanden der die kanzlerkandidatenfrage
gerne in den nächsten tagen und wochen
entscheiden möchte und auf jeden fall
nicht genug um einen führungsanspruch zu
untermauern
am sonntag möchte armin abschätzig
zusammen mit hits markus söder der im
gespräch mit der unions fraktion stellen
bis dahin wird er noch einige punkte
sammeln müssen
die einschätzung von chuck und lebendig
vielen dank dafür nach berlin
beim impfen hängt deutschland ja nun
hinterher
im zweiten quartal aber soll alles
besser werden
auch weil hausärzte und ärztinnen ab
heute im ganzen land mit impfen
die verfügbare impfstoff menge ist aber
nach wie vor eher überschaubar alle
praxen zusammen erhalten 940.000 dosen
in dieser woche also gut 26 pro praxis
einen echten schub soll es ende des
monats geben
christina eglseder und
fabian köhler am frühen nachmittag kamen
sie endlich die ersten impfdosen aus der
apotheke die eigenen patienten selbst
gegen korona impfen können
darauf hatten sie hier in der
gemeinschaftspraxis im niedersächsischen
giesen bei hildesheim schon gewartet
unterm strich mit dem stoff mutter mit
einer patientin nicht
35.000 niedergelassene ärzte mit ihnen
soll das impfen jetzt fahrt aufnehmen
die nachfrage ist groß der impfstoff
aber nach wie vor mangelware
wir werden diese woche eben wie gesagt
nur 140.000 dosen bekommen das wird dann
hoffentlich zum ende april aufwachsen
damit wir unser ziel bis zum sommer eine
herdenimmunität durch impfung zu
erreichen näher kommen die jetzt die
gänge so der deutsche hausärzteverband
reiche da noch nicht wir müssen so viel
impfstoff bekommen wie wir bestellen wie
wir patienten impfen können und nicht
sozusagen abwarten dass die impfzentren
bedient werden und wir kriegen dann im
grunde genommen den rest die impfzentren
hier auf dem land seit weg der weg zum
arzt des vertrauens dagegen kurz dass
ich jetzt hier gleich dran komme ich bin
ja auch immerhin 76 jahre alt das finde
ich schon sehr sehr gut und da bin ich
auch hier der praxis damit war ins
berechtigt auch in den praxen zur zeit
nur besonders gefährdete personen
der hausarzt kennt sie trifft die
auswahl
das ist ein ostern wie ich es noch nie
erlebt habe also nur am telefon mit fünf
sechs leuten kann man patienten
angerufen dass wir die alle einbestellen
für diese woche schwung bringen ins
impfen mit tausenden von hausarztpraxen
so die hoffnung so dass ab jetzt
schneller und runder laufen die
impfungen in arztpraxen antworten auf
viele fragen hierzu haben wir in unserer
app zusammengefasst etwa wie termine
vergeben werden wer zuerst dran kommt
und welche impfstoffe es dort
mittelfristig geben wird ein bisschen
öffnung wagen das will das saarland
ungeachtet der dritten infektionswelle
ein modellprojekt das kanzlerin merkel
sehr gewagt nennt trotzdem bekommen alle
mit einem frischen negativ test ab heute
eine spur freiheit zurück dürfen etwa
ins kino ins fitnessstudio oder draußen
essen gehen bei wieder steigenden
infektionszahlen soll es war eine
notbremse greifen aber erst wenn das
gesundheitssystem überlastet sei würde
wieder heruntergefahren heißt es susanne
freitag voller optimismus baut er seine
terrasse auf auch wenn das wetter
ziemlich mies ist sie setzten fest auf
die frisch getesteten saarländer die ab
heute wieder draußen sitzen dürfen
auch wenn 60 prozent der gastronomen
lieber noch etwas warten mit dem öffnen
das saarland modell geht pünktlich an
den start
ich freue mich auch mal einen kaffee
noch mal trinken zu gehen es ist
irgendwie hat es einem auch gefehlt in
der letzten zeit mainz bringt ein stück
normalität welche lieber noch eine woche
geworden für die ganzen wörter
abzuwarten was ist nach ostern wirklich
bei der
mit denen sie denn es werden rauskommen
hier wird seit heute wieder kontrolliert
geschwitzt das fitnessstudio ist
geöffnet den kurve test gibt es vor ort
sie haben extra noch alle mitarbeiter in
einer arztpraxis ausbilden lassen dass
die fachgerichte so ein corona test
durchführen können weil wir wollten halt
die hürde für die mitglieder nicht noch
höher machen eine notbremse tritt in
kraft wenn die inzidenz zahlen zu hoch
sind und das gesundheitssystem
überlastet ist was das heißt ist nicht
klar kritisieren experten
wir haben auch neben der britischen
variante auch die südafrikanische
variante einem sehr hohen maß hier im
saarland vorhanden
und außerdem sehe ich die notbremse als
schwierig definiert weil sie über die
auslastung des gesundheitssystems
definiertes und das ist nicht klar
definiert und da steigen die zahlen im
moment im saarland auch schon stark an
ist also jetzt im moment auf keinen fall
der richtige zeitpunkt für die eröffnung
das saarland wagt mehr normalität das
infektionsgeschehen wird bestimmen ob
das modell erfolg hat der blick auf die
infektions lage das robert koch institut
meldet sinkende zahlen
die sind wegen der osterfeiertage
allerdings mit vorsicht zu
interpretieren
denn es wurde weniger getestet und
gemeldet die gesundheitsämter
registrierten binnen eines tages 6885
neuinfektionen
außerdem kamen 90 weitere todesfälle
hinzu die bundesweite sieben tage
incidents liegt aktuell bei 123
die eu und die türkei
das verhältnis ist seit jahren schwierig
die flüchtlingsfrage erdogans vorgehen
gegen oppositionelle
der streit ums erdgas im östlichen
mittelmeer all das belastet die
beziehungen dennoch die
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen und
ratspräsidenten shell sind heute nach
ankara gereist
man müsse im gespräch bleiben sagen sie
aus der türkei berichtet lag bei pot
ein besuch in schwierigen zeiten bei
einem schwierigen präsidenten michelle
und ursula von der leyen auf werbetour
trotz demokratie abbaus einschränkung
von grundrechten und tausender
willkürlicher verhaftungen wie die eu
einen neustart mit erdogans türkei
wir wollen die beziehungen verbessern
aber wir stehen dabei natürlich noch
ganz am anfang des weges
für uns ist dabei wichtig dass die
türkei die menschenrechte und die
prinzipien der rechtsstaatlichkeit
einhält und entsprechende schritte
unternimmt
präsident erdogan ließ das unkommentiert
im erdgas streit mit zypern und
griechenland hatte er nach zahlreichen
provokationen zuletzt
gesprächsbereitschaft gezeigt brüssel
will im gegenzug über eine erweiterte
zollunion und reiseerleichterungen
sprechen und die eu möchte das
flüchtlings abkommen mit der türkei
fortführen und sicherstellen dass die
knapp vier millionen vor allem syrischen
flüchtlinge dort bleiben und versorgt
werden
dafür will europa mehr geld zur
verfügung stellen fordert von erdogan
aber die einhaltung seiner zusagen dazu
gehört die bekämpfung von schleppern und
die wiederaufnahme der rückführung von
flüchtlingen von den griechischen inseln
in die türkei die eu ist bereit zu
gesprächen wir werden dann beim
eu-gipfel im juni die ergebnisse
beurteilt scharfe kritik am besuch der
eu-spitzen kam von
menschenrechtsorganisationen
sie werfen den europäern vor nicht genug
gegen den abbau der grundrechte in der
türkei zu unternehmen keine
auslandseinsätze sondern heimatschutz
das ist der grundgedanke des neuen
freiwilligendienstes denn es seit heute
bei der bundeswehr gibt junge leute
bekommen zunächst eine militärische
grundausbildung in den einsätzen dann
geht es aber mehr darum bei katastrophen
oder unglücken zu helfen oder eben auch
ganz aktuell im kampf gegen die pandemie
das interesse an dem dienst ist groß es
gibt aber auch kritik frank buchwald
soldaten die helfen die bundeswehr
kämpft nicht nur in mali und afghanistan
sondern auch hier etwa gegen
dollar oder naturkatastrophen
heimatschutz speziell für einen solchen
freiwilligen dienst bildet die truppe
nun junge menschen aus wir stellen fest
dass wir in deutschland gerade in der
jüngeren generation durchaus das
bedürfnis haben dem land und den
menschen in diesem land etwas
zurückzugeben und sich zu beteiligen
die freiwilligen erhalten eine
militärische grundausbildung ihre
aufgaben jedoch heimatnah wachschutz
etwa oder katastrophenhilfe reserve aus
der region
sie brauchen keine lange einweisungen
sie sind in der lage schnell tätig zu
werden sind aber auch in der lage aktive
truppe in der dauernden schule sitzen
die heimatschützer bekommen regulären
sollte und verdienen damit erheblich
mehr als freiwillige in zivilen
einrichtungen sozialverbände laufen
sturm
jetzt kommt die klare ansage
jeder soll da diese soldaten ist uns
mehrfach so viel wert wie du die du im
kindergarten oder in eine
pflegeeinrichtung den freiwilligen
dienst absolviert das geht einfach nicht
das muss dringend korrigiert wird
auch die gewerkschaft der soldaten sieht
noch offene fragen etwa bei ausrüstung
und budget die bundeswehr sei kein thema
wege nimmt anna zu können wo sind die
abgrenzung zwischen technischen
hilfswerk rotem kreuz und auch der
bundeswehr denn die amtshilfe ist nicht
kernauftrag sie ist nicht struktur
begründet ja wir retten leben aktuell
wir sind im notfall da aber noch mal die
bundeswehr ist im kern für die landes-
und bündnisverteidigung mit dem
freiwilligendienst will politik die
bundeswehr stärker in der gesellschaft
verankern seit langem aber kämpft die
truppe gegen personal not deshalb steckt
hinter der neuen strategie wohl auch die
absicht nachwuchs anzuwerben
er selbst bezeichnete sich als loyalen
katholischen theologen was sie nicht
daran hinderte den kurs seiner kirche zu
kritisieren
hans küng ist heute gestorben mit 93
jahren
der gebürtige schweizer legte sich mit
gleich mehreren päpsten an aromen entzog
ihm die lehrerlaubnis seine bücher aber
erreichten ein millionenpublikum
petra otto erinnert an hans können
die lehre von der unfehlbarkeit des
papstes dagegen stemmte er sich ein
leben lang hans küng priester um
kirchenkritiker bis 2013 leitete er die
stiftung weltethos weil es keinen
frieden ohne einen frieden der
religionen gebe ich kann mich darüber
freuen dass sich die programm worte die
ich vor vielen jahrzehnten schon
ausgegeben haben langsam ins bewusstsein
der menschheit eingeprägt haben schon
mit 32 wird der gebürtige schweizer in
tübingen theologie professor teenager
theologe nennen sie ihn den jungen
kirchen rebellen hier trifft er auch auf
joseph ratzinger und schreibt den
bestseller unfehlbar anfang einer
dauerfehde mit der katholischen kirche
diese entzieht ihm 1979 die
lehrerlaubnis hans küng zutiefst
gekränkt finde es einen skandal dass man
in einer kirche die sich auf jesus
christus berufe und die menschenrechte
verteidigen will
noch immer in position möglich ist
2005 trifft er dann doch wieder seinen
alten weggefährten ratzinger inzwischen
papst in rom
doch hans küng steht zu seiner kritik
prangert den katholischen reformstau und
den umgang mit den missbrauchsvorwürfen
er bleibt sich eben treu aber die
entscheidende frage damals so wie ich
mich beuge in sachen unfehlbarkeit des
papstes pille und so weiter also da bin
ich froh dass ich stark gehalten habe
hans küng ist tot seine unbequemen
fragen und forderungen aber bleiben
einen ausführlichen nachruf sendet das
zdf um 0.15 nach dem heute-journal
abstellt und nun zur
fußball-champions-league da stehen ja
zwei deutsche vereine ja heute abend der
bvb gegen manchester city
morgen abend titelverteidiger münchen
gegen paris st germain die wiederholung
des finales von 2020 auftritt der besten
mannschaft der welt so heute uli hoeneß
und meint natürlich seine bayern paris
steht vor der tür auch kein schlechtes
team das die bayern im finale letztes
jahr besiegen konnten
bei uns hat es hat es keine relevanz
weil neue spiel auch eine neue
mannschaft
paris hat neuen trainer also von daher
andere voraussetzungen
der sieg in leipzig letzten samstag
klappte auch ohne torjäger robert
lewandowski der ist weiterhin verletzt
sabri kann nach einem positiven corona
test nicht spielen er ist in quarantäne
wir wollen viertelfinale wir wollen ins
halbfinale deswegen müssen wir die zwei
spiele sehr konzentriert angehen
das ist unser ziel und nach unsere
aufgabe denn das beste vereinsteam
europas wollen sie bleiben den titel
gilt es zu verteidigen ja noch ein
viertelfinale morgen abend im dfb pokal
zweitligist jahn regensburg gegen werder
bremen die oberpfälzer mit einer
spektakulären serie drei siege im pokal
wettbewerb alle nach elfmeterschießen
regensburgs torwart maier ein echter
elfmeter spezialist zuletzt verzweifelte
auch köln an ihm der rest besorgten
treffsichere schützen gerne nochmal so
meint ihr trainer
das wäre dann optimal wenn das so läuft
1 1 internet meter schießen dann sehen
wir wahrscheinlich dann war da seine
bremer kollegin ist nicht bange vor
elfmeterschießen obwohl torjäger
füllkrug wegen zehenbruchs ausfällt ich
trainiere ja auch ab und zu mal elf
meter schießen nach dem training und
einzelne spieler machen es auch immer
wieder so dass unsere schützen im
rhythmus sind sollte es dazu kommen aber
wir versuchen alles zu tun um es früher
in unsere richtung zu lenken
besser wärs denn regensburg hat ja
torwart alexander meier und das was im
sport danken aus sonne wolken regen
schnee und glatteis das aprilwetter hat
wirklich alles im angebot
in einigen teilen deutschlands hat der
winter noch einmal richtig zugeschlagen
träumen dienst und schneeschaufeln
mussten ran
zum beispiel im erzgebirge es gab viele
unfälle wie etwa hier in niedersachsen
auch lastwagen hatten große probleme auf
dem spiegelglatten straßen wo sie morgen
früh mit neuschnee und glätte rechnen
sollten das sagt den gleich katja huhn
ist das war es von uns danke für ihr
interesse
das kleber erwartet sie um 21 45 zum
heute-journal und wir freuen uns wenn
sie auch morgen wieder einschalten punkt
19 uhr einen schönen abend wünschen wir
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
er nahm meine damen und herren das ist
klassisches aprilwetter kaum ist eine
schneeschauer abgezogen kommt schon der
nächste hinterher und es gab auch einige
regenschauer das sind die blauen flächen
kräftige gewitter waren auch dabei und
das ganze passiert einfach weil es in
den hohen höhen so wahnsinnig kalt ist
mit diesen schneeschauern haben das auch
noch jetzt in der nach zu tun die ziehen
dann über deutschland hinweg dann
beruhigt sich die lage vorübergehend
aber schon in der zweiten nachthälfte
kommt ein neues kleines schneetief heran
und bis morgen früh zieht das bis nach
bremen ins westliche niedersachsen und
nach nordrhein westfalen
dann müssen sie sich also auch sehr
gefährlich glatte straßen einstellen im
laufe des tages zieht dieses schneetief
über hessen und thüringen weiter nach
bayern es streift auch baden württemberg
und rheinland pfalz im norden geht der
schnee schon wieder in regen über
zwischen den ganzen schneeschauern gibt
es heute nacht auch etwas platz für den
sternenhimmel und es wird frostig kalt
temperaturen von minus 16 grad nur an
der küste bleibt es ein bisschen milder
und überdies temperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen null und maximal 8 grad an der
ostsee und sie sollten sich weiterhin
auf glätte einstellen auf kräftigen wind
und graupel gewitter sind morgen auch
dabei in den nächsten tagen beruhigt
sich das wetter es wird auch wilder
schönheit noch